direction los che à présent pour une
visite de chantier mais pas n'importe
laquelle le palais de justice abandonnés
par l'état depuis dix ans va enfin
reprendre vie c'est un hôtel quatre
étoiles qui va trôner sur la place de
verdun qui en profitent pour se faire un
grand lifting
au total une rénovation à 7 millions
d'euros 45 chambres livraison prévue à
la fin de cette année visite guidée du
futur hôtel de la cité royale avec
audrey champigny voilà à quoi
ressemblait encore la salle d'audience
du palais de justice de loches en 2009
date de sa fermeture dans cinq mois
maintenant ici se trouvera le restaurant
bistronomique de l'hôtel côté réception
plus de sept mètres de hauteur de
plafond et un gros travail de rénovation
des pierres pour garder la pièce dans
son jus on va allier le contemporain et
l'ancien et
et donc on a dû faire une ascenseurs et
qu'il faudra juste derrière la réception
au sous sol
on a creusé des salles de séminaire un
espace cowher king est le must pour un
quatre étoiles
donc nous voici dans la partie bien-être
avec la piscine et jacuzzi et hammam
derrière moi donc notre clientèle pourra
être dans la piscine avec vue sur la
cité royale est également derrière toute
la partie massage qui sera avec accès
pour la clientèle extérieure également
que pas que pour la clientèle de l'hôtel
à l'état chambres individuelles ou
familiales avec boiseries d'époque
mezzanine terrasse et vue imprenable sur
la cité royale prix moyen d'une nuit 100
euros sur le parvis là aussi les
aménagements commence fini le goudron la
place de verdun sera totalement
végétalisé avec 60 nouveaux arbres
replantés un grand my piétons et
toujours du stationnement
initialement il me semble qu'ils
allaient voir 154 places ici sur notre
projet final on est à 148 donc on
enterre quelques-unes
toutefois quand on va réaménager la rue
alfred de vigny on va recréer une bonne
trentaine de places sur tout le linéaire
de la rue donc le bilan global est qu on
aura plus de place une fille née quand
tout sera terminé
aujourd'hui pour la municipalité
l'ouverture dès l'été prochain de ce
nouvel hôtel est un argument
supplémentaire pour l'attractivité de
son territoire
je suis content que ce soit dans mon
mandat on s'est battus quand même pas en
six ans pour
obtenir en fait ce projet san hôtel 4
étoiles déjà donc j'ai une offre qui est
différente qui est un peu plus haut de
gamme avec probablement déçus les jours
qui seront plus longs des possibilités
de séminaires on est en centre-ville on
a une vue formidable sur la cité royale
donc effectivement ça on va voir une
clientèle supplémentaire en fait et
nouvelle donc pour loges si l'aspect
initial du bâtiment a été respectée deux
extensions ont été rajoutés sur les
côtés une note de modernité qui
nécessite encore quelques petits
changements pour garder l'unité
architecturale du lieu